sociologue et directeur de recherche au
cnrs auteur de l ouvrage une
insurrection populaire au destin
incertain bonjour merci d'être avec nous
alors à votre avis cette rencontre entre
emmanuel macron et ce groupe de gilet
jaune
est-ce qu'elle va avoir lieu alors elle
pourrait avoir lieu
est-ce qu'elle va changer profondément
les choses non parce que finalement elle
n'engagera pas le mouvement des gilets
jaunes dans son ensemble donc par
exemple si on estimait qu'à l'issue de
cette réunion une pause soit décidée
elle n'aurait pas elle n'aurait pas
d'effectivité parce qu'encore une fois
les personnes qui sont cités comme
pouvant représenter le mouvement de fait
ne le représente pas puisque je rappelle
que le principe même de ce mouvement
égalitaire c'est précisément qu'il n'y
ait pas de porte parole officiel
et pourtant le président sur
l'agriculture il avait bien précisé à la
personne qui l'avait interpellé vous
venez en groupe et je vous reçois
l'elysée c'est ce qu'il a dit grosso
modo à 7
oui la même il a même il est même il est
même allé plus loin puisqu'il il a dit
bon structuré vous et puis je vous
reçois donc quelque part ils violent
encore une fois l'esprit de ce mouvement
qui n'est pas un mouvement qui permet de
dégager des leaderships quelle que soit
la valeur des individus voire parole ce
que vous expliquez c'est une erreur
alors pour ce groupe là de s'être
justement structuré oms on peut dire les
choses ainsi pour une fois c'est malin
jérôme rodriguez prescillia le dos qui
oui mais enfin encore une fois qu'ils
sont des représentants médiatiques du
mouvement mais je pense que l'europe
représentativité ne va pas au delà
donc je crois que c'est aussi peu
conforme
à l'esprit des gilets jaunes que d'avoir
présenté des listes aux élections
européennes par exemple là nous sortons
encore une fois de la logique première
de ce mouvement
est-ce que des discussions avec l'elysée
c'est possible dans ce cas de figure
parce que tous les gilet jaune ne
peuvent pas se rendre à l'elysée pour
discuter que le président avait les
grandes les grandes revendications des
gilets jaunes sont connus et depuis
depuis longtemps en particulier
peut-être
la mesure majeure aujourd'hui qui est le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
je crois que pour faire un état de la
question je dirais que nous sommes
passés d'une guerre de mouvement ce qui
a été le mouvement pendant plus d'un an
et demi à une guerre de tranchées à une
guerre d'usure
tout continue je pense que c'est à une
guerre sociale que nous assistons
aujourd'hui avec des foyers un petit peu
partout hein
c'est une sorte de deux virus positif
puisqu'il s'agit d'améliorer la
situation sociale d'un grand nombre de
français aujourd'hui
vous pensez qu'il ya d'après le
communiqué en tout cas du groupe qui
s'est constitué pour rencontrer le
président n'y a toujours pas de réponse
de l'elysée c'est un peu trop tôt
peut-être penser qu emmanuel macron il
va aller au bout de sa démarche
bailly serait quand même bien avisés de
respecter l'engagement l'engagement
qu'il a pris puisque là il ya un certain
nombre de figures qui se présente savait
mais ya déjà eu des rencontres alors pas
au plus haut niveau mais des rencontres
entre certains représentants des gilets
jaunes et des représentants du
gouvernement
il ya quelques mois ça s'est déjà
produit voilà mais pour encore une fois
un effet qui a été à peu près à peu près
nulles alors les gilet jaune qui se
mobilisent à nouveau pour un acte 68
samedi dans le même temps il ya toujours
aussi ces manifestations
interprofessionnelles contre la réforme
des retraites c'est le cas aussi des
avocats qui était battu le pavé hier en
tout cas se sont mobilisés à travers un
acte devant le tribunal de nanterre est
ce que
il y à un point de convergence ce que
c'est une réussite ou est ce qu'on
aurait pu encore aller plus loin au
niveau du mouvement des gilets jaunes
justement pour converger et donner plus
de poids à au mouvement savez la
convergence c'est comme la réussite ne
se décrète pas donc il est évident qu'il
ya des foyers de contestation qui ne
sont pas éteints qui sont toujours là
donc on ne peut pas parler de ces
différents mouvements au passé ce serait
vraiment très très près très très
prématuré et puis les les grandes
questions qui ont été posées au fil de
ces mois la crise de l'hôpital public
qui ressurgit à travers l'épidémie du
coronavirus bon on voit bien que les
moyens manquent et pourrait manquer
cruellement si cette épidémie venait à
s'étendre encore encore davantage bon la
crise manifesté par les avocats
concernant leur régime autonome
bonds est toujours là également la
situation des policiers n'est pas n'est
pas améliorée il y aurait tant d'autres
questions qu'on pourrait te présenter je
pense notamment la crise de la
surpopulation carcérale qui fait que
nous sommes épinglé par les instances
intentia halle depuis des années est ce
que la crise des banlieues qui existe
depuis 30 ans est résolu non elle n'est
pas plus résolue voilà est-ce que la
crise de la paysannerie française dans
les règles un petit peu d'enfermement de
l'union européenne est résolue pas
davantage voyez est selon vous les le
mouvement dit gilet jaune
il a
et va se poursuivre encore et se
relancer oui parce qu'encore une fois il
y à il ya des procédures qui avancent
parallèlement bon on le voit bien avec
la réforme des retraites il ya d'un côté
la procédure parlementaire qui va
probablement arriver à son terme
prochainement mais qui mettra pas fin à
la contestation sociale social et
politique
j'ai en mémoire l'exemple de la fameuse
loi sur le cpe en 2006 la loi avait été
votée promulguée
et elle n'a pourtant jamais été
appliquée voyez donc encore une fois la
procédure parlementaire ne résoudra pas
ne restera pas là les questions pour le
reste la grande misère la grande
détresse de beaucoup de nos concitoyens
elle est toujours l'un les problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat ne sont pas réglés
j'étais en train de faire mon propre
calcul par rapport à ma pension de
retraite
elle a un petit peu augmenté mais dans
le même temps les loyers des logements
augmente donc pour le coup votre pouvoir
d'achat il est mangée par par les
petites augmentations des pensions de
retraite
merci beaucoup michel fize je rappelle
que vous êtes sociologue directeur de
recherches au cnrs auteur de l'ouvragé
l'insurrection populaire au destin
incertain
merci à vous merci